All right guys, I'm going to talk about
some stuff to do with uh cumulative
volume delta today. So,
if [clears throat] you're not familiar
with what delta is, essentially it's
kind of a way in which you can measure
aggression in the market. So, positive
delta means buyers are more aggressive,
negative delta means sellers more
aggressive.
If you were to look at, for example, the
total delta of a candle, uh you would
take the net buys minus the net sells,
and that would give you the total delta
of a candle. So, not what I'm talking
about today, but there's kind of two
different reads you can get on order
flow, at least to me. Uh you have your
kind of contextual read, which would be
like, "Okay, what's happening around
this level?" Or, "What has been
happening since X?"
Uh and then you have a bar-to-bar order
flow read, which would be like, "Okay,
like what happened at this absolute
inflection at this high?" Like, "What
happened in in this candle?" Right?
And that would pertain more to like
uh a footprint chart, for example. So,
um
>> [clears throat]
>> what I'm talking about today is
cumulative delta or CBD, which really is
the aggregation of aggressive buying and
aggressive selling over a certain period
of time. So, uh whether it resets at the
end of the day, session, or it's just
rolling, ultimately you can still kind
of see the correlation between, you
know, what price is doing
and what CBD is doing. So, is there, you
know, are they normal? Are are, you
know, are they in sync? You know, this
made a new high, this made price made a
new high, CBD made a new high, kind of
thing.
Um or is, you know, something different
happening? Is there a dislocation
between what price is doing and what CBD
is doing?
Um
and with that, you know, order flow or
CBD shouldn't form trades for you on its
own, right? Always need to have a way to
find narrative and mark your levels and
inform a bias on and on. Um and I do
that through using VWAPs and composite
structure with with kind of AMT in the
framework that I have.
Um so anyways, CBD basically looks like
this. So, you can see there's there's
obviously correlation. So, you can see
like this high, for example, coincides
with this high, right? This low is this
low, right? So, that's where you can see
the difference between the two. So, um
one issue I have with what people
or how people teach this or really
anything order flow or even just
analysis related, whether it's paid or
free content, is they go and find the
most picture-perfect example of
something, put it in a video, but more
often than not, nine times out of 10, it
never looks like that on a chart. So,
that's one thing I make sure I don't do
in any kind of education and content
that I provide or record. It's all raw
charting and all and all kind of
real-world examples. So, anyways,
and that pertains more to order flow
more than anything I find. But anyways,
the the main thing I want to touch on
here is divergences. So, what people
will often look for with CVD and price
is a divergence or a difference between
the two. So, let's say that, you know,
the two main things you'll see, and this
can be, you know, vice versa, could be
at a high or a low.
Say this is resistance here.
And say this is price and this is
cumulative delta. Obviously, they're
stacked here. I have them
side each other here, but doesn't
matter. So, say this is resistance,
okay? And let's say price does, you
know, something like this. It makes a
higher high and CVD does this.
Okay? So,
lower high and a higher high. There's
obviously a difference between the two
here, right?
And this is a way to see exhaustion or
weakness. So, price is continuing, but
ultimately, you know, the aggregation of
aggressive buying and selling is that,
you know, it looks weak, you know, it's
gone down. It was unable to break this
high where price did break this high.
All right? So, this is a way to see
exhaustion, which could potentially, you
know, could you could fade this and go
short, you know.
Um so, that's one example.
The other being seeing absorption. So,
it's kind of a divergence the other way.
So, it would be, you know, this is
price, this is delta.
So, you have something like this, okay?
And CVD does this.
Okay? So, obviously, the aggregation
here is saying that, you know, there is
aggressive buying here, um
but aggressive buying is unable to get,
you know, result for the effort here
because it's being
absorbed by a passive seller. So, in the
market,
there's two kinds of participants here.
So, there's aggressive, you know,
aggressive participants, which is like
you and I,
uh to put simply, and then there's
passive participants, which are, you
know, large limit orders, right? So, if
it you know, if an aggressive
participant or participants are unable
to
push price, you know, they're not
stronger than the passive participant,
um that's what you'd call absorption.
So, that you know, the divergence here
is that CVD made a higher high and price
made a lower high.
Okay? So,
the issue with that is that it has
nothing to do with swing structure
itself. So, that's what most people will
see and that's what, you know, is often
taught and what people are looking for.
But, the issue is that it has absolutely
nothing to do with swing structure. It's
all about result for effort. Okay? So,
what if you have this? Is what I'm
getting at here. So, say this is
resistance again.
Let's say that, you know, price is doing
this, okay?
It's doing that and CVD is doing this.
Okay? So, regardless, this made a higher
high, this one didn't. It's all about
what does it look like? What are the
traits or what are the characteristics
of what each of them are doing? So,
price is continuing one. Let's say this
is going up and this is actual PA.
One, the candles look weak. Okay? These
are weak candles, right? You know,
there's no real aggression here.
And conversely, two, you look at CVD,
um you know, this is rather flat. Again,
this looks weak, price looks weak,
right? One's still kind of going up,
one's flat or slowly going down. It's
not about the fact that one broke the
swing high and one did. It has
absolutely nothing to do with that
because that could that's totally in
relation to what price is doing. What if
price is doesn't do that, right? It's
all about the dislocation between the
two, right? And and you know, that's the
problem is that people will simply go
ahead and look for a divergence and if
there's no divergence, they're unable to
identify what's actually happening.
Whereas, there's about a million
different things you can do with
cumulative delta.
But, this specifically alone is just
taught completely incorrectly, in my
opinion. Has nothing to do with the
divergence. Of course, if there's a
divergence, then you know,
that's present, but ultimately, that's
just not how it works a lot of the time,
right? It's not about picture-perfect
examples, it's about real-world
examples. So, let's Let's look through
some stuff here. Maybe there'll be some
divergences, but the biggest thing to
take away here is it's all about
result for effort. You know, how much
effort did buyers have to put in here
and how far did they actually push price
in regards to,
you know, the actual effort they put in,
right? And you can see that easily
because with cumulative delta just
because there's a correlation between,
you know,
this high is this high, this low is, you
know, this low, right? This is this,
right? So, you can see the correlation
between the two, you know, rather
easily.
Um and it's a popular thing that people
like to look at in kind of this order
flow bubble, I guess you could say. So,
let's just walk through some examples
here of what actually happened. I may
miss a couple things here. I'm just
trying to put this into a video format.
I'm not going to look at every
individual blip of Bitcoin here. Um
the gray box is a multi-day composite
just for reference. So, let's just kind
of look at,
you know, what happened around,
let's just say here. So, start at this
low.
So, again, this low is this low. It's
inside of the composite. Okay.
You get this rotation, right? This is
normal, right? You can see this
aggressive candle on CBD, you see it on
price, okay? It trades up into the
composite high, finds resistance there,
right? Pretty normal, right? And it
makes a lower low. Right? Same thing
here. Makes a lower low. They're pretty
much in sync. I would say price did go
lower than CBD if you actually measured
from here to here and then here to here.
That's the dislocation you're looking
for, but ultimately this isn't very
meaningful, right? They both are in
sync. They both made a lower low, okay?
Following that,
you can see that,
>> [clears throat]
>> you know, we kind of get this, you know,
compressive behavior around here,
compressing, compressing, and then
ultimately it's able to trade back
inside of the composite.
Okay, back inside of the composite,
trades back up. Again, here's here's the
the difference here. So, look how high
this high is as opposed to this high as
opposed to this high and this high. So,
these are much closer than these. Again,
this isn't meaningful, but this is what
I'm talking about. This is what I'm
referencing here in this video. But
again, not a trade location doesn't
necessarily matter. So,
doesn't matter. Let's just keep going
along.
Following that, right? You can see that,
you know, this is rather weak. This
finds weakness here, rotates back, it
retests the valve again. Um
right? And again, there's still kind of
a a dislocation here. You can see that,
you know, this low is almost equivalent
or almost equal with this low. And you
can see that, you know, there's a big
difference. This only retraced about 50%
of this move.
Okay?
So, something worth noting. That's what
I'm talking about here.
Following that, this is where, you know,
you start to be able to identify actual
rather weakness or actual weakness here.
So,
uh you can see price is going up, CVD is
going up. That's about perfect
correlation, I would say, between the
two.
You'd see that, okay, kind of a weak
weak price action, right? Weak price
action the other way can be seen on both
cumulative delta and price.
Uh and this is where it starts to get
more interesting. So, you see how low
this low is?
How low this low is?
And then you look at them on price, and
you can take a look at this one here, as
well. So, you can see that, you know,
it didn't go lower than this low, so
it's a higher low, but it I mean, it
came pretty close, but ultimately, if
you want to go and look at the
correlation between the two, you can see
that, you know, how low this low is.
This made a lower low. So,
this would be identified as absorption
here, okay? So, this is this is
aggressive selling, and they're not
getting a lot of results for their
effort, right?
So, that's where, okay, things start to
change. So, the biggest takeaway is
that,
you know, what is normal,
right? So, you can see that there's a
correlation between the two, so
everything's in sync, so you shouldn't
be looking, you know, to fade any of
this, right? When there's no
difference between price and CVD, that's
normal. You want to just go with what
price is doing, go with what CVD is
doing, right? Seek to go with, you know,
what what the strength kind of picture
looks like.
Uh following that,
you can see that price makes a lower low
here on CVD, whereas price does the
opposite here, right? It's not
Again, it this is where we talk about
swing structure and stuff. It doesn't
matter. To me, this is compression,
right? We're compressing price is is an
ascending wedge against resistance, and
you can see we get an aggressive move
back inside. Whereas, CVD goes down. Has
nothing to do with swing structure
itself.
Um And then at that point, we're back
inside of the composite, and this is
where it starts to get even more telling
from here. So, you can see that CVD is
still going down. Ultimately, it looks
weak, but especially this last really
compressive push here. Okay, which led
to an aggressive move, which it almost
always does. Um this is an even larger
divergence. So, you can see
Just delete all these.
You can see that again, this low is this
low here. That was the first divergence.
Right, we're just going to call this a
low and this a low just for simplicity's
sake. But, you can see that
this is a higher low, right? If if we
were to draw, you know, a line from this
low to the high,
which is, you know, this high here.
Okay?
Look how much lower this goes. Of
course, this is a divergence, but it's
all about again, results for effort.
This is so much lower.
Right? And then you look at price action
in context. We traded back into value.
We found support here.
Sellers are still put trying to push
price lower, and ultimately it it's it's
this kind of ascending wedge, right?
This is what I would call compression.
Right? And it just gets tighter and
tighter and tighter until it leads to an
expansive move. Which can be seen here.
Okay? So, again, results for effort.
That's the only takeaway from what
cumulative delta is doing majority of
the time. It's not about swing structure
at all.
>> [snorts]
>> Uh right. Let's just go along and see if
we can find a couple more examples worth
noting here.
Just delete that. And let's go along and
look.
Uh again, pretty much in sync here,
right? Price is trading higher. CVD's
trading higher. Nothing really worth
noting here. Again, you always want to
look at what, you know, it's all about
context. Order flow is nothing without
context, in my opinion.
Um doesn't form trades on its own.
Again, same thing here.
Price makes a higher high, CVD makes a
higher high, everything looks good,
right? Aggressive candle here on Delta,
aggressive candle on price.
Um and then this is where it kind of
starts to get a little bit weaker.
Again, this is where I talk about swing
structure does not matter. This it's not
about one made a higher high and one
didn't. It's about what is the
characteristic what are the traits of
price and Delta? Are they different? Are
they same? Does one look weak? Does one
look strong? Do they both look weak? Do
they both look strong? That kind of
thing. So,
you can see that this obviously is not
strength, right? It's at very best this
is a range. To me, it looks like it's
just going to trade lower. You can see
CVD
it is also range bound and it's kind of
trading lower. Whereas price, again, it
it's weak. Right? So, this is, you know,
this entire move
again, we talk about divergences. If
someone, you know,
a lot of people probably don't see this
as a divergence because again, it's not
that clear, you know, price and and
CVD scenario. Whereas you can see that,
you know, price is ultimately trending
higher in this little bracket where
CVD's doing the opposite, it's going
lower, okay? So, this again is a sign of
weakness. Whereas if you were just going
off of these picture-perfect divergence
examples, this wouldn't be seen at all.
Um
So, following that,
you can see that again, CVD trades much
much lower. We talk about a dislocation
between the two.
Right? This low coincides with this low.
Um
This low coincides with this low. So,
you can see that this low rotated almost
all the way back to this low here.
They're almost exactly equal, whereas it
only retraced about 50% of the move on
price.
Right? So, again, there's another
dislocation between, you know,
you know, sellers tried this hard and
they only got this far kind of scenario,
if you get what I'm I'm saying here. Uh
and then following that, you can see
this aggressive pick up. So, this can be
seen on both price and Delta. So, again,
you know, this isn't something you'd
want to fade. Um if context called for
it. Of course, it doesn't here. Um so
you can see CVD
goes up, price goes up.
So again, those are definitely
you know, correlation they're they're
definitely both normal here, you could
say. Um and then you can see, you know,
we take out these highs and then that
marked the top. But ultimately again,
another big dislocation. This high is
this high. This low is this low. And you
can see that, you know, CVD only
retraced again about half the move if
that. And this actually swept the high.
So this is an example of okay, buyers
got aggressive here.
You know,
they they got a lot of result for their
effort, but ultimately they were still
they still failed up here, right?
But again, there's an example of that
kind of dislocation.
Um
so let's go along and see if there's
anything else worth looking at.
Again, I always like to do these
extremely raw. I just it's no like BS
around here, no no So
uh following that [clears throat] again,
you can see that
following that move, everything looks in
sync. Price is going down, CVD's going
down. You get this aggressive move here.
Right, this flush
can be seen on both of them. And then
you can see that CVD continues down,
right? So there's another divergence. So
sellers are trying to push price lower
here. Price is going up. And then
ultimately it leads to another
aggressive move as as sellers around
this level, right? They are forced to
close, leads to uh push to the upside.
And again, there's still a big
dislocation here. So
as much as again, we talk about highs
and it's all about results for effort,
right? Look how high this high is, look
how low this low is.
And and
this high marks this high here. So this
is this. So this little move here
rotated all the way back up to this
high, whereas on Delta, it retraced
what? 30% of the move.
So that's just showing that okay, you
know, almost almost no effort was
actually required to get back up here,
right? So there's a big dislocation
there.
Uh following that, let's take another
look at this. Again, we're still
rotational in this composite context is
always most important.
You You see that
you know, following this
this is rather weak, whereas CVD is
going up.
So again, it doesn't matter. Swing
structure doesn't matter. That's not
what I'm talking about here. We're
talking about CVD slowly climbing, price
slowly going down, dislocation between
the two. Okay?
Same thing here. CVD picks up.
Price picks up. We talk about another
divergence here. Right, here's a high on
price. Here's a high on CVD. CVD, right,
goes much, much higher. Actually, it
rotates all the way back up to where,
you know, this kind of high was put in
around here. Right? CVD goes much
higher. It makes a higher high, clearly.
Right? And this coincides with this
high.
So, talk about a dislocation. Did
did CVD go anywhere near where this high
is?
Right? CVD
in regards to this high is way up here.
And look at this one. It's here.
Okay, so there's a massive dislocation
there. Uh and then even just in this
structure here, right? We talk about
identifying the weakness here. CVD is
climbing, right? So, there's buyers
being absorbed.
Price is weak. Okay? So, weakness,
absorption.
Okay? So, another thing people look at.
Um
you can see weakness and absorption in
multiple different scenarios seen in one
kind of contextual read on order flow.
It's never that straightforward. Um
and again, that's one of the things I
hate about what people do with this
stuff. Showing picture-perfect examples.
It doesn't really work like that
most of the time.
And again, example here. Another
divergence.
This high here and this high here. Did
did price go anywhere near
this kind of distance? No. Right? This
puts in a new high. This puts in a lower
high. This puts in a higher high. That
would be, you know, absorption. That's a
divergence seen across that level.
Um
and then following that, right, it
trades much lower.
All right, another breakdown.
You can see that this is pretty much in
sync from that point. Um
another rotation. So, buyers tried to
get more aggressive here So, this can
also be seen as a divergence, but again,
you don't What I'm trying to get across
here is that you're not looking for
swing structure one to make a higher
high and one to make a lower high, for
example,
or higher low.
Lower high, rather. Uh it's all about
the difference between the two, right?
This high is this high. This low is this
low. This made a higher high. This
didn't even retrace 50% of the move.
It's not about the structure. It's about
Okay, buyers really tried here in
regards to reading cumulative delta,
this aggregation of buying and selling,
and they only made it about 40% of the
way back up.
Whereas, you can see here, right, it
went way higher.
And you can see even CVD, right,
following this. You can see weakness
just on delta and its characteristics,
too, as well.
This is weak.
Right? And what else do you know? You
know that okay, if if buyers are unable
to
trade it higher from here, they're going
to be forced to close. So, I know that
because
they're not getting here, right? They're
not getting results for their effort,
which they aren't, right? Given you can
see the dislocation between these, it
leads to a move back down, right?
They're forced to close, they have to
market sell, and you can see that again
also on delta because you get this large
dump in delta, and then it just trades
lower from there. So, again, just want
to talk about that. A lot of people
approach CVD the wrong way. Um
anytime I do kind of education stuff
like that, I always show raw examples of
me charting stuff. I don't like people
that that, you know, go along and find
picture-perfect examples, and then when
you go to the charts,
you know, 90% of the time it just
doesn't look like that. So, just another
example. Hopefully, you guys found this
useful, and uh have a good one. Cheers.